Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and his time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Dan Checking in on.
Yeah.
I'm just checking in on you.
How are you?
How's your week going?
I hope you're,
uh,
help you're accomplishing things.
I hope you have a sense of purpose.
I hope that uh,
that
Douche with the bad breath in the fucking terminal head cold,
that content doesn't walk by your cubicle today.
You know him fucking coming down the fucking hall.
Um,
anyways,
I am in a,
I'm in a great mood.
Believe it or not,
I just uh,
I finally got,
I tell you guys are saying,
you know,
I was trying to take the uh,
the old timey door locks out of my old timey doors,
my old timey fucking house,
which by the way,
I had an architect come over here.
I was going to do it right this time,
you know,
for the whole fucking idea that I was going to have to make a drum room in my
garage or whatever.
And,
you know,
the whole thing went to shit.
And I'm not going to tell you why because I don't need the fucking hassle man.
But I just,
I found out the fucking history of this house and,
um,
you know,
I didn't want to get into it.
Tony,
you want to get into it?
Just,
you know,
fuck it.
Just forget it.
I had a dream and it went in the shitter.
Um,
is it,
I swear to God I'm,
I'm,
I'm in with this fucking house.
There's no turning back.
So anyways,
I'm just,
I'm just putting my head down and I'm fixing every fucking goddamn thing in this
fucking house that was painted over Jerry rigged.
Not done with the fucking,
I don't know who bill a fucking mailman built half of his fucking house.
So anyways,
I got these,
uh,
these old door locks and of course some dose paid this other Douche to come in
here and he just painted over everything.
Well,
she did.
Okay.
I don't really branded as sexist here.
A woman is just as good with the paint brush as a man is,
if not better.
There are certain studies on scratch my twat.com that actually indicate that a
female.
Um,
so I finally got the,
uh,
I finally got the door,
looks out of my door and I brought him down to the old fella down the street,
the locksmith guy and I gave him three,
two of which were original,
none what?
And another one was a newer like home depot style ones.
So he goes,
this new home depot,
when I can't make a skeleton key for,
it's a big fucking pain in the ass.
I think I have an older lock from the same era is your other locks.
So I said,
well okay,
let's do that.
And I was like,
all right,
you'll give me a shout when you,
when you get these things done.
And I said,
you know,
preferably one key would be able to match all of them like a skeleton key and
can I also get one of those cool looking skeleton keys instead of some modern
looking key?
And he goes,
oh,
absolutely.
He goes,
that's the only key that'll work.
And guess who fucking called me right before I sat down two days,
two days later,
this guy called Becky has to lock fixed and all that shit.
So now in my office there's a,
you know,
I got two little closets.
I can lock both those doors and I can lock the main door.
And then the,
when you go into the bathroom,
um,
you can,
uh,
that one I had fixed last year,
so they'll all fucking work.
You know what I love about it is Nia was giving me shit going like,
what the fuck are you pulling all the doors apart?
You know?
And I tried to tell her,
and she just kept going,
you are not a locksmith.
Just kept giving me shit going,
you're going to fuck up the house.
I go,
no,
and I'm gonna do it.
Just kept going,
Yo,
not a locksmith.
Um,
and then just was openly laughing at me,
um,
as she does,
which of course made me laugh at myself,
but I got these fuckers out,
um,
by,
of course,
going on youtube and learning how to like get these things off without stripping
the,
uh,
the screws and all that.
I found this great youtube video of this guy goes,
all right,
you just stick the screwdriver in there and you give just a little bit of
pressure and then you just sort of tap it lightly with the hammer,
you know,
and that loosens up the paint and then eventually you were able to turn the
thing and God damn it,
if it didn't work,
it worked on all of them except the ones that I stripped from being too fucking
impatient.
So I have a bit of a problem on a couple of doors.
But anyways,
um,
I got three of them down in this room and I've got about another five to go.
And then unfortunately I,
there's another couple of doors that,
um,
you know,
we'll replace with those awful home depot one.
So I'd like to get some new ones.
And I know what you think.
And like Jesus Christ,
Bill,
what's with all the doors in your house?
Old houses had a lot of doors,
not a lot of square footage,
not a lot of big closets or anything,
but the,
God damn it,
they had a lot of doors.
And despite the fact that everybody back then seem to own maybe one suit that
you got married in and you know,
buried your friends in and all of that shit.
Like for some reason they had an unbelievable urge to lock things up.
Okay.
You know
what they had back then,
then maybe they would pan and for gold and shit.
I don't know.
I don't know what you would have a value back then,
right?
Everybody walking around looking like Johnny Appleseed,
why do they have so many door?
Um,
so anyways,
that's like the big fucking highlight of my day.
And,
uh,
also speaking of which,
I've watched the,
uh,
the Bruins replay today at them playing,
the Columbus blue jackets.
And once again,
another great game was great to see Adam McQuade come back.
And as much as Marshawn scoring streak ended,
Louie Erickson's has kept his going and a fucking broad man.
I'm telling you,
I can't stress it enough.
Like I was go,
they got rid of Lou Cheech and all those guys.
I was like,
we are going to absolutely suck this year and we are a solid fucking team.
Um,
so anyways,
so I'm watching the game and at one point,
I don't know if anybody watched the game,
they were doing this camera angle where it was almost at like the top of the
building.
So it'd be like if he had like upper deck seats so you could really watch like
the play develop.
Um,
and I just thought it was a great camera angle.
If the NHL wanted to get more,
of course they want to get more.
Right.
Of course.
They want to get more fans.
They want to make more money.
It's like the NFL.
I was talking to somebody last night and they were trying to claim that the
fucking Jacksonville Jaguars might move to London.
All right.
And I don't mean Connecticut,
isn't there a London and Connecticut,
London,
England.
Like,
that's how we're going to,
that's our first move to make NFL football worldwide.
We're going to take our worst fucking franchise
and put that thing on point.
Um,
evidently it's owned by some,
uh,
I think Pakistanian or something.
And who lives in England?
I have no fucking idea.
That's what somebody was trying to tell me.
I have no idea.
I was in a bar.
People were talking,
I was nodding,
my eyebrows were up going,
Oh really?
Rarely.
And now I'm just telling you what I heard.
I haven't looked any of this.
I didn't even Wikipedia the bullshit.
I'm telling you right now.
So take all of that with a giant grain of salt.
Throw it over your shoulder and you know,
do your little Sammy Sosa Kiss your fingers.
Ll Cool j thank right.
Anyways.
Um,
okay.
I think bay,
I know sitting there going,
why the fuck would the NFL wanna put a team in London?
Like why can't you just be happy being like billionaires?
Like isn't that enough for you?
And I think they're jealous of world cup soccer because as much as the
Superbowl's this giant thing,
or we think it's this giant thing,
it got like,
I guess like 80 to 100 million views or something.
Once again,
I'm just throwing these numbers out there,
but recently like a soccer or football is what I should really call it,
considering that's what the world calls it.
MMM.
Do you know it's funny when they say they go,
why do you call it football when you carry it?
And it's just like,
it's like,
I don't know,
somebody had the great joke,
but why don't you call it feet ball?
You know,
you'd be able to use both of them,
right?
If you want to be fucking clever.
Cons about it.
Um,
so anyways,
football,
World Cup football had a sum game that was just some regional final or whatever
the fuck it was.
A friendly,
whatever the fuck they call it.
It's one of those ones that isn't the World Cup.
And it got like a billion views.
Like out of the seven and a half billion people on this fucking planet.
MMM.
It got a billion fucking views.
So this sitting they go,
we got to go global with us,
Shit.
And our first move is going to be descending evidently the Jacksonville Jaguars
out to fucking London,
England to a bunch of fish and chips and cuts.
Um,
anyways,
I'm fucking with you.
So anyway,
so much in that the,
the Bruins game.
So they do this camera angle from up top of the building and you can really
watch the play develop,
especially if you're like a novice fan of hockey because the fact that they're
to the side,
you know,
if you've played hockey and you've gone to enough hockey games,
like you actually have to watch,
you got to know what's going on,
like three feet off of the screen,
you know,
like literally like you'll see a team bringing the puck down the ice and a guy
flips it into the zone and then the entire team disappears as the camera follows
the puck.
Now if you know,
watch hockey,
you're going like,
well,
what the fuck to everybody just quit.
Where'd they go?
You don't realize that?
Oh,
it's a line change.
Um,
now with this angle you could do that.
And I was actually thinking what would be cool as you know,
the NFL has those cameras on fucking why
they should do that.
They should have a camera.
Like I would say that you should run a line right across the red line
that they still have,
even though they don't even use it anymore.
Okay.
And you have one camera pointed down,
one end and the other down the other and basically you just follow the puck up
the ice,
um,
as you normally do throughout the whole game.
But anytime there's like a power play or if a team establishes,
you know,
themselves in the offensive zone,
you would then cut to that camera and you could really,
you could basically see what everybody was doing because a lot of times when it
goes out to the point,
you can't see what's going on.
If somebody down behind the neck,
you could just be,
you know,
seeing the entire thing.
And then the second it fucking,
you know,
the other team gains control of the puck and they comp the ice.
He just flip back to that traditional view that they always show.
And Oh,
freckles,
fucking brain was going when I was watching this and I was thinking,
you know what,
I bet in the future they'll have something like that and probably they'll end up
having cameras in the helmets and you'll be able to add home,
act like the guy in one of those Monday night football trucks and you'll be able
to direct your own game.
And then the NHL would have like a show us your best edit of fucking,
you know,
whatever McQuaids slap,
slap up from the point or whatever and you get to show your,
your,
uh,
your edited version of the fucking game.
Like in the future,
just be able to flip around and it'll drive everybody fucking nuts who's trying
to watch the game.
And then there'll be an old grizzled cont like may God,
I'm old school.
I looked at TV,
dictate the angles,
you know.
Um,
but anyways,
I just thought it was like a really cool
way to watch the game.
And,
and um,
the NHL is,
was actually ahead of everybody else by having onscreen graphics.
They just came out too early and went too hard when they had the flaming trail
behind the puck and everybody laughed at him and ridiculed him and everything.
But now when you look at NFL football and they have like the first down thing is
all lit up and uh,
everybody's drawn all over the screens and all of that show.
I guess Madden was doing that beforehand.
Um,
I dunno,
I just thought it was a cool way,
you know,
something I,
I thought it was a good idea and then I set it out loud and I still think it's a
good idea,
but I really just bombed in the presentation.
But I'm,
speaking of which,
as far as like hockey,
I guess Las Vegas,
even though they haven't been awarded a team yet,
is just gone ahead and just as building a stadium that evidently is going to be
one of the best stadiums in the league if they're allowed in the league,
which is exciting and really fucking annoying to me as a Bruins fan,
one of the original six teams,
the fact that we just went down to home depot,
as I've always said,
and just bought 50,000 fucking cinderblocks and built a rectangle considering we
used to play in the Boston Garden,
which was one of the fucking,
you know Meccas I don't want to use that fucking Madison Square Garden world.
It was,
it was a fucking church.
It was a cathedral.
It was an old barn.
It was the shit.
All right.
And the fact that we just,
you know,
the fact that the Dallas Stars have a better fucking,
Minnesota wild,
they got a bit,
they got a way better,
way more personality and shit to those fucking venues than what we have is a
goddamn crime.
So now in Las Vegas,
that building a fucking arena for a team,
they don't even have yet.
I just saw it like halfway completed.
I've got to look at this.
Fuck,
this place looks amazing.
So I immediately started thinking like,
well wait a minute.
Vegas is going to have a team.
What would you call the team?
Now,
back in the day,
you could call them what they should be called.
This should call them like the gamblers.
You know,
remember the Houston gamblers,
they had the gamblers back in,
uh,
the USFL days.
They were the Houston gamblers.
But you know,
there's no fucking way,
there's no fucking way they'll do that.
They should call him the fucking Vegas Gamblers,
right?
And their mascot should be like this degenerate gambler,
Just look at some broke ass guy,
just,
you know,
but it's,
it's a,
it's a fucking mascot look and things.
So it's,
it's funny,
kind of like being the town drunk used to be funny before they said,
no,
he's an alcoholic,
he has a disease and you know,
all the foster Brooks guys,
stop losing.
Stop getting work.
You know,
you know it's going to fucking happen.
All these fucking Goddamn Pansy fucking soccer mom,
mini van driving Douche bags,
they're going to end up calling them like,
I don't know the Geckos of the road runners.
Yeah.
No,
not even.
They won't even call him the sidewinders.
You know,
cause well that's a poisonous snake and,
and you know,
we don't want to scare the children.
Okay.
You know,
I just,
I don't fucking understand it.
Why can't you call him the gambles?
You have a degenerate gambler as a mascot and then you teach a kid a lesson.
You see that?
You see that fucking right.
That's what happens when you go on these goddamn casinos.
Okay.
All right.
No,
I'm not getting yet another fucking popcorn.
Yeah,
Nah.
Yeah.
Old School parenting old school.
Parenting.
Was it at one point during the game,
you took your kid too.
You made him cry.
All right.
And I'll tell you right now,
the day that that ended,
there was the day that this country started going down the shitter.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
what?
W what do you do?
I want to hear you guys' guesses.
What do you think they're going to call them?
Huh?
The maces,
the Pueblos.
He can't say pueblos though.
Those were,
there was a native American groups,
so they'll get upset.
The,
uh,
the star dust,
you know,
they're going to do that.
If you can't call a team that devil rays,
if you just got to switch it to the res because people are so fucking paranoid
that if you call it the devil rays,
that one of their kids is going to get fucking,
uh,
what do they call it?
Possessed of,
of,
of the name of a fucking baseball team or what,
what,
what a horrific is great as this stadium is as awesome as it would be.
I don't know why.
Like I'm,
I'm totally against teams being down in the sunbelt except in Vegas.
Vegas needs to have a team and you know what?
They should be fucking shifty,
shady,
any fucking thing that begins with the sh other than Shitty,
you know,
they should cheat.
They should have like a bunch of Ken Lynn Smith.
I don't want fucking knee breakers,
but they just used to be the cheapest motherfuckers in the league.
You know,
just old school fucking shit.
That would be great.
That's not going to happen.
They'll play,
they'll call him the fucking,
uh Oh,
what do they call them?
Something like that.
The star dust and they'll hire the first female head coach.
They just,
they're it.
They'll go that route.
That's the direction it's all heading.
You know,
we should have known when when times square went from like fucking a place where
you could jerk off while someone mopped it up simultaneously.
Right.
It's some one legged freak was doing her dance in front of you to go into like
the M and m store and now they have chairs where you can sit down in the middle
of the fucking street once,
once that went that direction.
How did I not see the direction?
That's sports.
We're going to go and you know that everyone was going to get a ribbon.
You know?
I don't know.
I don't even want to get into this.
I don't even give it a shot.
What happened?
I was in a great mode or hey,
I have got to live with these fucking door locks.
All right,
what are we into?
17 minutes into year checking in on you here.
Um,
what else did I want to talk about here in this thing?
Oh my God,
I lost my shit.
I had been doing so well with my temper lately.
You wouldn't know it from this podcast,
but all Billy's been making some strides.
Um,
I don't want to happen about a month ago,
I started to flip out when I was in the car.
No,
I was at an airport.
That's right.
Car Airport.
When you get to my age,
it's all the same thing.
It's some form of transportation,
whether you're in it or standing,
trying to get on it.
It's all it gives.
It just sorta all blends into one thing and then all of a sudden you're just
like,
it's Christmas again.
That's what getting old is.
All right.
You don't know where you are and all of a sudden it's Christmas again.
That's basically what you have to look forward to.
All right,
so what that depressing thought.
Let's plow forward.
So we're in this,
we're at the airport and I went to the sky cap,
you know,
rather than going to the fucking electronic faceless cut thing that I'm supposed
to,
you know,
that can't read my
credit card and all of that horseshit and is what one person to help 70 people
on these things.
I go to this fucking guy and uh,
he ends up shooting the shit with somebody else he takes for fucking ever.
And I was starting to lose my shit as I do,
as I do.
I don't have control of my emotions.
My emotions have control of me.
Um,
my wife just tapped me and she just goes,
given a minute.
It's all she said,
And for some reason,
I don't know why that is just stuck in my head.
And as I,
you know,
more times than not,
when I start to flip out,
I just think given a minute,
take a breath,
just given them an a and it's been really fucking work.
And for me about,
you know,
11% of the time,
um,
which is,
you know,
whatever,
11% better.
So last night I get in the car,
it's fucking raining out here.
So you know,
the deal,
you'd starts to rain out here,
everybody freaks the fuck out because you know,
they're not used to,
I don't know what the deal is.
I guess there's a bunch of
fluids from cars just builds up and it doesn't get washed away.
So yeah,
I guess the roads are a little more slippery.
But anyways,
so I'm driving to pick my wife up,
right?
And I'm at this red light and I'm the third person in line at the red light.
Okay.
So when you're the third person in line to make a left in Los Angeles,
your eyes are fucking locked in on the movements of the person who's in the pole
position.
And you need that fucker to make a move.
Okay?
Take a little bit of risk or you're not going to make the light.
So I'm just sitting there locked in on that thing,
like my fucking pit bull,
when it hears a noise at the front door and it's fucking ears goes up and it's
such going low,
right?
And it's fucking hair.
That's,
that's the fucking mode I'm in.
And do you know,
I watched this stupid La Cunt,
all right?
Or whatever transplant,
not going to blame the city here
goes to make a left stops.
Okay.
Stops.
There's somebody in the crosswalk so the person stops.
Okay.
And then the traffic that's trying to drive through one person is making a right
where that person's making the left.
So they're waiting for the person that crosswalk and the other person is trying
to make a left.
So this person is not blocking because both people are turning,
one's turning on the same street as the fucking lefty cunt and the elements
going the other direction.
Do you know?
For whatever fucking reason,
this asshole,
like I don't know what they did.
They just,
a person got through the crosswalk and then rather than going,
I,
and I'm like three cars back on what?
You know what they did?
You're never going to guess.
They backed up and got back in line,
backed up in fucking,
was it 2007,
nine years coming up on nine years of living out here.
That is the most fucked up moron move I've ever seen.
And you want to talk about not giving it a minute and absolutely losing your
shit.
Aye.
I literally was in the car and went,
you fucking fucking and then said the word that isn't acceptable now anymore.
It used to mean you're a jerk.
Um,
and also begins with an f.
And then what I did was,
you know,
it was funny right after I did that because I yelled and I had to do a show.
I reached into my console and I put a lodge in my mouth.
Okay.
And I immediately laughed at myself and saw how ridiculous I was.
Big.
I really wish I could control my emotions more.
Um,
I've never noticed cause I grew around,
I grew up around a bunch of fucking hotheads and I never realized like it's
finally dawning on me as I approached the fucking half century mark.
Um,
it's,
it's finally dawning on me a what?
A weakness that is.
Yeah,
I know it because it's just dawning on me now.
I can't really articulate it.
It's one of those,
those,
uh,
one of those Mama,
I'm trying to think of them,
Hollywood movie I've seen where somebody just gets caught up in their own
fucking power and then halfway through it they're like,
wait,
but we're the victims,
right?
Were what the fuck movie was that,
ah,
Shit.
Who's this great movie with?
This guy was getting picked on and then he just took fucking control and then he
started abusing his power and then the end,
he just sorta kinda dawned on him that,
wait a minute,
and I w w
I'm right,
right.
As he sees,
seen the fucking hurt that he caused other people.
And I want to say,
blows his brains out.
Add Jesus Christ building.
You know,
it's what he got to fight a dollar for every fucking movie.
I la,
I forgot.
You know,
I'd have a good 250 bucks.
Um,
all right,
let's,
uh,
let's read a little advertising here for this.
Uh,
for this Thursday afternoon,
um,
headspace.
All right.
Let's be honest.
Most of your problems start with your mind.
Fear,
anger,
stress.
Oh,
Jesus was not,
was I not telling the perfect story?
Fear,
anger,
stress,
anxiety,
depression,
sleeplessness.
They begin in your head,
but they can wreck your life.
MMM.
Please include all of the falling points during your read.
Ah,
why did they write that?
I'm going to read everything you wrote.
All right.
I've said this on numerous episodes.
Okay.
But it doesn't have to be that way.
You can make a major difference in just 10 minutes a day.
The change comes through guided meditation.
I need the shipment with the new headspace APP.
Headspace is meditation made simple.
It's guided meditations that you listened to whenever you want,
wherever you want,
right on your phone,
computer or tablet.
Meditation is rooted in thousands of years of tradition and we're going to take
that tradition and throw it out the fucking window and let you do it as you
drive down the highway.
Um,
you know,
recently I saw yoga instructor saying he was quitting it because like all of
the,
it's been distilled down to just get in the fucking killer body,
you know,
anyways,
with thousands of scientific studies that show its positive effects,
like improving focus and relationship harmony and decreasing anxiety and stress.
Join over 5 million users already getting some headspace man for free right now.
MMM.
I don't understand.
Well why I would need to be able to do it.
I guess.
What if I'm on the road?
Okay.
And I'm in the quiet of my hotel room.
You know,
as I listen to the people fuck on the other side of the wall,
I am able to block it out through deep breathing and focusing and quieting my
mind becoming one with the universe.
Hey,
they're fucking,
maybe I'm fucking too,
it's a threesome.
Now download the free headspace APP and begin their take 10 program for 10 days
of guided meditation@headspace.com slash burr the headspace take 10 program is
100% free.
It's a hundred percent freeway to experience the benefit of meditation and
you're busy,
modern life.
Learn how to read out loud better without stumbling over your words.
Train your mind for a healthier,
less stress life.
Start with your free trial today at headspace.com/burr that's headspace.com/burr
okay,
I'm smiling now.
Trunk Club,
every bud buddy,
every bud,
trunk,
clump,
clump.
Don't waste a second of the new year in a crowded mall.
What Trunk Club you can make 2016 your most stylish year yet.
And the best part is you won't have to do any of the work yourself.
You know what I just realized the most arrogant thing you could ever do,
you know is a rich person is your joint trunk club and that person has to go
down the mall and some psycho goes down there,
pulls out a gun and does one of those mass shootings and you still bitch that it
took too long for the trunk to get there.
Even though that person went down there,
which should have been you when they had to go down there and dodge the bullets.
Oh,
I don't give a shit what happened.
Okay.
I am going to bed tonight and I need my top seat out 2016 it's going to be a
game changer.
You're fresh starts stat the year off on the right foot and the right pants with
the right jacket over the right shirt.
Fuck working on yourself as a person.
You got to get the outfit,
man.
Trunk Club is here to handle your wardrobe so you can focus on what matters the
most.
Please include all of the following points during your read,
Huh?
Many times.
Do I have to say it?
Trunk Club takes the Hassle,
man out of shopping by finding the best clothes for you,
for you and your style.
You'll look like 1 million bucks or at least a couple hundred and we'll always
have the perfect close for this season@trunkclub.com slash burr you answer
simple questions about your style,
your preferences and sizes,
and you're excited.
You're assigned an expert stylist
who isn't working in New York City or Paris.
They're working for trunk club.
Your stylists will hand pick clothes from the best premium brands.
Just approve of what you like and send back what you don't.
Just like that a trunk arrives on your doorstep.
And they went down there and they risked.
They risked their lives,
they wrist,
you know,
all guides.
I don't know.
They had to find a parking spot.
You don't have to deal with shit filled with handpicked clothes that are perfect
just for you.
Try them on,
keep what you like and he's a return.
What you don't.
And the prepaid trunk trunk club is not a subscription service.
You only pay for the clothes you keep from your trunk.
No hidden charges,
just get just great clothes.
That's it.
It's fucking great.
You never have to go to the mall again,
you know.
All right.
Oh,
I thought it was over.
Call the action slash offer.
It's a brand new year full of possibilities.
And with Trunk Club you'll start the year off looking great and close picks just
for you.
Uh,
get started today called Trunk Club was that was in the trunk club.com/bird.
That's trunk club.
Com slash birth for trunk filled with clothes.
You'll love wearing additional points dimension.
These aren't required,
well then I'm not going to do it.
Zip Recruiter.
The final one.
As a business owner,
your company is only as good as the people you hire.
Well,
no shit.
Posting jobs at one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
Short staffing leaves little time to post to dozens of job sites,
positions,
zip recruiter as the solution.
I am the solution everyone Zimbra
you know,
why could you can post to 100 job sites with one single click,
click be instantly matched to candidates from over 6 million resumes.
Plus Watch brand new candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface with twin within 24 hours.
Zip recruiter has been eat,
been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Um,
today you can try ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/bar
hi,
ziprecruiter.com/burp.
All right,
that's,
that's it for the reasons.
Yeah,
this week here.
Um,
all right.
By the way,
did I,
I mentioned,
uh,
I told you guys earlier,
now you know that I'm an old curmudgeon here,
the middle aged curmudgeon.
I mean,
I don't know if I'm middle aged at this point.
47 times two is 94 not a lot of people get to 94.
I'm an over the hill guy.
Who's kidding?
Who could,
who could still bang out fucking 10 pull ups.
Huh?
He liked that Dash Dash Dash Dash.
Um,
what am I saying here?
I,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm one of these fucking people that I do not give it up to young people right
out of the fucking gate.
I don't give a fuck how good a game you had.
I don't give a fuck how good his season you have.
I want to see the career.
And you know,
that whole crown of king began somewhere at the beginning of shacks career that,
that fucking,
you know,
when you came into the league and you already had your own fucking sneaker,
you know what I mean?
Um,
yeah.
So I never give it up to people until like,
you know,
people going to Tom Brady's the greatest of all time.
I still was going like,
well,
Joe Montana has four rings and it only took them four times to get it.
He won with nobody's,
he won with superstar teams.
All right.
So,
okay.
Until this guy does something above and beyond him,
the best he could do is be on his level.
I'm one of those guys,
having said that,
Steph curry is the greatest fucking shooter of all time.
I believe.
I already think that.
So I made it,
uh,
a promise as a sports fan that I was going to try and see him this year.
Um,
well,
uh,
see him as soon as I can while he's still fucking young and he's in his prime.
You know,
you gotta do that.
Like I saw Jordan when he still had hair,
you know,
so,
um,
it turns out I was hanging out at Lago last night doing a,
the great Tom Papa's show down there and Al Madrigal from all things comedy,
the creative force,
the brains,
the brawn behind all things comedy.
He was down there and he's a,
he's a bay area guy and he watches every single golden state warriors game.
And he said,
you know what,
he goes to the warriors are in town this Saturday.
So I,
uh,
I woke up this morning by Dubai Bordeaux boob.
I went on Stubhub,
go do to do,
do it.
And I paid through the fucking nose for two fucking great seats.
Um,
yeah,
I'm going to go Saturday night.
Fuck it.
I gotta see this guy and I'm going to get there early for the shoot around.
So,
cause I want to see him put on a show and I'm hearing people talking about how
fucking unreal it's just to watch the guy shoot around.
And it's reminding me of when I went to a San Diego Padres game back in May of
1998 I remember me and this comedian dance Smith,
now the Boston guy.
We went down there and it was,
we saw a mark McGwire and this is when they,
you know,
this is when they were,
uh,
you know,
going after the Roger Maris record,
and everybody was having Andrew Steam delivered to their house and their wife's
name.
I'm actually going to look it up.
I'm going to find you the exact fucking date.
San Diego Padres,
1998.
Schedule the fucking hilarious that this still exists.
That some who to fuck look this up today.
1998.
San Diego Padres schedule.
I remember it was may 20 something.
Where the fuck was it?
It was a cat nose.
All right.
This is some fucking,
oh Jesus Christ.
They had the games numbered rather than the date you fuck out there.
There's the date.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
So sorry.
Come on.
Where is it?
Right.
They're like
fuck yourself.
Five 29,
1998 or five 30 or five 31 it wasn't June.
I remember it wasn't June.
I went to one of those fucking games against the Saint Louis cardinals and we
got there early and we watched mark McGwire take batting practice.
And um,
if there's any footage of that,
if you could have been there and watched the performance this man put on and you
still think that performance enhancing drugs should be illegal.
You're out of your fucking mind.
These people are special.
These people are better than us.
Okay.
You know when you take a Prius to the fucking gas station,
do you put the fucking,
the put premium super fucking the best gas.
You don't.
You give it the shit gas,
right?
Did you pull up in a fucking supercar you give it to you put the best fuel in it
that you can.
All right,
and you know what it is.
I don't think it sees athletes fall.
I think it's the people in the crowd.
We don't want to admit that.
Where'd you well,
you know we are,
we're a bunch of Toyota Prius.
This what we are,
bunch of Ford escorts and we deserved that shit food that they feed us and fuel
our bodies with.
As we sit there and just getting the hightest in the fifth inning from all the
booze and fucking hot dogs,
you weight these fucking athletes.
They're better than us.
They're special.
They need the high octane fuel and they should go out there and put on a fucking
show and fill up our lives.
Right.
Anyways,
I'll tell you right now,
I would rather watch a fucking roided up athlete take batting practice than
watching all natural one breakdown at 35 and remind me that I'm going to die
someday.
You know what I mean?
I want him to be superhuman.
I want their head to be three times this size.
It was before they started their career that those people,
they're heroes,
they using themselves as Guinea pigs.
They put that shit in their body.
They didn't know what the fuck it was.
They didn't know what the fuck it was because they wanted to make you happy.
They wanted to hear you chair,
right?
They wanted to see a little kid go,
boy,
oh boy,
this is the greatest time ever.
And then they wanted to go out and have their choice of pussy after the gape top
shelf,
high octane,
fucking Victoria secret pussy.
And they,
God damn it,
they earned it
all right.
You'd walk it around letting somebody shoot horse horse tranquilizers into your
fucking ass,
you know?
And then what do you get?
What do you get?
What do you get to as a thank you.
You got to sit in front of the Senate.
They make you cry.
If I was running this nation,
no,
I,
this is where he got big day.
I loved that athletes,
she used performance enhancing drugs and I hope they continue to do it because
as much as people are condemning it,
we learned things by them using them and eventually they're going to figure out
how to make them safe.
And when I'm old,
what?
I'm old and you guys go to see me at a casino when I am 94 and I am fucking
jacked with a full head of fucking hair.
You can thank the mark.
Mcguire's.
Okay.
Deg To fucking die.
The other,
whoever the fuck else took it.
I don't know where the fuck I,
you know who gives a shit?
You could thank Peyton Manning's wife.
All right.
If she didn't blow out her fucking shoulder taking those cookies out of the oven
and she didn't need that shit.
Goddammit.
Can somebody please make a picture of me at 94 Jack with a full head of hair
wearing a Tuxedo,
playing the stardust,
cheering on the Vegas.
Gfe shut the fuck up hill.
All right,
that's the end of the podcast here.
Everybody have a wonderful weekend.
I'm going to make a little video of my,
my new door locks when I get them in there and I'll be excited about it and you
guys can shit all over it because it's the internet.
All right?
Yeah.
Fuck you too
slowly
fill
reason.
Oh,
gone crazy.
Oh Man.
Last night
I was sitting on the couch booboo to Lou due at nine in my own fucking business.
Ludo Ludo I was watching metal mania on VH one.
Metal Mania.
Cleo.
Okay.
I think my dog is sleeping with him with his eyes open.
Oh No,
she just moved her eyebrows.
Okay.
Do,
what the fuck did you just go?
Huh?
Cleo?
Whatever you're thinking about,
it's going to be okay.
All right.
Anyways,
you know it's weird when my dog sees a squirrel through a window.
If it cries
like,
like it's a long lost buddy.
But if my dog is outside and there's a squirrel,
you know,
if there's no window between my dog and the squirrel it,
we'll try and rip his fucking head off so I don't,
does anybody know anything about dogs?
What is it crying about as it crying?
Like,
Ooh,
I want to rip its head off.
Oh,
I wish I could just end.
That thing's fucking life.
Yeah.
You don't make any sense to me anyway.
So I'm watching fucking metal mania alliteration.
This has gotta be a hit show,
right?
So I'm watching this shit and uh,
yeah.
At the risk of pissing off a lot of listeners,
I think most metal slash hair metal,
it arguably is the worst fucking music ever made.
Worst of disco.
I don't know why disco gets such a bad rap.
Like disco was the,
is the default example of bad music.
The Way Hitler is,
the default example of,
of evil duties.
The next Hitler,
it's always the next fucking Hitler never pull pot.
You know,
never fucking,
I dunno,
picking up,
I don't even know another one.
You know Ivan,
the terrible,
was that a wrestler?
Was that a comic strip?
I know.
Horrible.
Haggar don't fucking know.
Right.
See,
I don't even,
I don't even have any other examples.
Okay.
Whose fault is that?
Build is a library right down the street.
I'll go fuck yourself.
You know what I'm saying?
Um,
everybody always talks about disco and how bad disco was and it just needs to be
a change man.
Right.
And like then they'll talk about like the police and all this new wave shit and
the punk scene and all that.
But what they completely fucking ignore is that right after disco and it just
immediately the mainstream then went over to like this fucking heavy metal music
like that was better than disco.
I think it's fucking worse.
And I think all these times where they keep saying that everybody there was a
big change and that this quality music came out.
I don't know if that happens.
I think it just,
you know,
nirvana comes around and there,
what,
four years later everybody's listening to fucking old town or the main stream
is,
it's just this long,
tragic,
just flatline of shit music.
I was watching the shit last night,
shit that I used to like and my jaw was on the ground.
How fucking bad it was.
It was horrible.
I,
I actually,
I was so bad.
I was like texting paragraphs to the sensation.
Joe Derosa capitol records.
The guy who built capital records.
Joe Rosa,
I'll actually,
you go,
well,
I'll,
I'll get a little intimate here with you.
I'll read you the text message.
I've fucking wrote Joe.
Uh,
Joe,
where the hell are we here?
Where the hell are we?
Joe?
Hair slash heavy metal is the worst music ever made.
Disco gets a bad rap watching metal mania on VH one.
Guns and roses.
Queens,
Rick Wasp.
Quiet riot.
David Lee Roth Solo Shit.
It's fucking God awful.
Yeah.
I saw David Lee Roth on,
on his,
uh,
Itam and smile tour and I saw that video last night.
Go wing crazy day
from day.
He,
that sounds like a song Wahlberg's character would have written with John C.
Reilly and Boogie nights.
Remember that?
Okay,
he will rock you
and we'll whoa.
You like it was,
it was that bad
teenage Frankenstein.
I'm a teenage package died.
You're telling me that that song is better than more than a woman?
You know,
I,
I think arguably it's,
I dunno,
I can't believe the shit that I used to watch.
And like I used to listen to this shit around checks,
you know,
just hopelessly thinking that this would get me laid.
Like they would think that I was some Badass like loner.
Okay.
Bag your
yeah.
I mean the whole fucking,
the fact that I never got laid in high school,
it just fuck it went away right in that moment.
It was like,
this is what I was going to do.
I wasn't going to try to make them laugh.
I wasn't going to hit on him.
I wasn't going to try it.
I was just going to play this music around them and this was going to bring me
to the fucking promise land,
looking like a fucking teenage Ron Howard.
That was my game plan.
Is it any wonder I failed Jesus Christ?
And I remember I would be watching it
on a big square TV.
Um,
just watch it,
lay it damn fuck horrific fucking music.
And my dad would come in and just have his face would just be all twisted up,
gone.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck you listen to you like this shit.
And I thought I was a rebel,
Amit.
He doesn't know.
Understand man.
You know what?
He totally understood.
My Dad called it back in [inaudible] 83 called it jungle music,
says a bunch of shit.
Told me straight up gay man.
He was like,
son,
this music you're listening to is fucking horrible.
And there was all these shout at the devil.
Is anybody really going to sit there and defend that fucking song?
Doodoo delay
Du du,
Du Du,
Du,
Du du Du du Du du Du du Du
can find you could fucking a five year old could write that on a xylophone.
Shout at the devil.
Never knew why we were shouting,
you know,
blacking lawless,
laggy,
lawless,
that was his show named Eddie.
He took a radial arm saw and cut the blade in half and put one hat,
one blade,
uh,
one of his forearms at one or the other on these leather.
Uh,
I'm gonna do a bunch of dishes in an evil way.
Gloves.
Yeah.
Oh,
we all thought it was crazy.
Can you imagine if we gave you a forearm shiver?
It was just Eddie used to throw fucking raw meat.
Go to the crowd.
A couple of them did.
That's why that lady Gaga covering or clam and that fucking Pastrami,
it's just been done,
you know,
comes out in a fucking egg from Mork.
I Dunno.
Same.
The nasally horror act my whole fucking life.
You know those fucking checks with the big noses.
They can,
you know,
that's like white people's answer to the big black girl who can sing at church.
We,
we,
what,
what the,
what the check we bring to that fight is the,
the white chick with the big nose white chicks with big noses can sing.
I don't know what it is.
Barbara Streisand.
Yes.
Right.
I don't know.
It's like their nose is,
it's like that dome at the top of all those con con,
uh,
concert halls.
There you go,
Bill.
Try to spit it out.
You dumb fuck.
But,
um,
I want some emails,
people,
I want people try to tell me
how a rowdy crowd by Vida Wigan.
Damn.
It'd be,
tell me the musical validity that that has over like disco,
that all those people probably had Comiskey plaque when they blew up those disco
records like fucking five,
six years later.
That's what they were listening to.
Okay.
Nope.
That was a hit.
That was a hit in the 80s
wow.
Do I owe my dad and apology?
I just,
I was sitting there just one video after the queen's Reich.
I mean,
all this stuff that I thought was just fucking unbelievable.
You know what?
I'm going to get emails this week.
It's like,
I don't know what it's going to be.
It's going to be like people either going to be like,
yes,
absolutely is this is going to be,
there's going to be no middle ground.
He wasn't going to 100% agree with me or a,
I'm going to get punched in the face by Eddie trunk.
I just,
I was taken aback.
I mean,
I haven't seen those videos and fucking forever ks.
You.
I'll go back and I'll look at some old videos,
but I mean,
a lot of it was like ACDC,
like shit.
They can like,
you know me back in black is timeless.
There's some timeless shit in there.
You know?
I even watched that guns and roses,
sweet child of mine,
and I thought,
I thought it was horrible.
Well,
and that little fucking Shim Sham dance he was doing was,
oh,
and then the emotion he tried to have in the end.
Wow.
All right.
And they kind of closed his eyes like,
ah,
I really went somewhere when I've,
I was just fucking horrible.
You know,
I was right down.
I help hold it up.
Oh,
Def Leppard pause should rob me.
I hated that when that fucking came out.
And all the ladies liked it and he came out in his acid washed jeans.
I actually saw him on that tour.
Okay.
Deny.
Yeah.
Reynolds' Coliseum in Tesla opened up Tessa,
which I didn't think they were that bed.
They weren't that bad.
I don't know.
I thought you're supposed to go back and listen to the fucking music of,
uh,
of your youth being like,
wow,
that stuff was all,
that was awesome,
man.
Remember that?
And then,
you know,
that was the first time I tried blow,
reminiscent
actually first time I ever saw cocaine,
uh,
saw it and saw it being done was a,
at the providence civic center.
I saw ACDC on the who made,
who tore with loudness,
the Japanese heavy metal band that couldn't speak any English yet,
sang in English.
Um,
I just can't imagine the disconnect as she's,
I can't imagine like memorizing a bunch of Japanese and going in over there and
just singing it and then not knowing,
uh,
what the fuck I was saying going out there
and everybody
like I have no idea what I just said.
Tee Shirts at 20 bucks.
Did I just say that or did I say,
are you ready to rock?
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
anyways,
so I saw them,
they opened up and uh,
anyways,
we're out in the parking lot and we're drinking beer stick.
You work crazy driving of course,
cause it's the eighties this is right around before,
right before mad kicked in and they used to bring like wreckage from a fatal
drunk driving accident.
Anybody else's highschool do that?
They actually brought a car from a fatal drunk driving
accident and they dragged in onto the lawn of our campus.
You want to call it a campus?
A little island with the tree.
They just left it there.
And we all just stared at it trying to figure out how many people were in the
car,
how many people died.
And then we just walked away.
Like,
you know when you're young,
you don't give a fuck.
10 minutes later you're talking about,
dude,
I can't fucking wreck tonight.
Rat.
That was the word.
Get wrapped.
Kittens destroyed Hammond,
right?
So anyways,
the driving down their beer between your legs as you do see eighties you know
you fucking lifted weights all that week.
Never all of it above the waist.
Curls.
Fucking Bension shoulders.
Nobody did squats in the 80s nobody did.
Right?
So you got your fucking tight five oh one blues on with the Little Pencil
fucking legs.
Then you overdeveloped upper body,
you stupid gold chain and a,
he had a beer between your legs.
That's how he did it.
So we're fucking going down.
There were probably on eight a piece fucking hammered.
Uh,
I was driving this piece of shit,
83 Ford Ranger.
I got like five fucking drunk friends in the back,
which was still not even grounds for getting pulled over.
You could just have people in the back like you were bringing fucking turkeys
off to slaughter.
Nobody gave a shit.
Right?
So we pull in and right as I pulled up and it got a parking spot,
there was this kid,
he had his door open and he kinda had like a Sammy Hagar meets John Fogarty
haircut blonde hair.
And I remember he fucking did align right as I was pulling up.
And I fortunately had my window up and he saw me and he saw,
we all had ACDC tee shirts on or whatever and he just got to the cow.
It's just so
it's like a haunted house right up to the fucking window.
And I was just trying to take it all in like,
okay,
he just,
how am I supposed to behave around somebody with,
with WHO's on coke?
Does this guy have like,
you know,
Hulk Strength Right now?
Is he going to tip over the truck?
Um,
anyway,
so that was the,
Fred was the first time I saw blow.
I didn't know what the point of all that was.
I was just shocked.
Look,
I know it wasn't all bad.
Like the steam early Metallica,
you know,
right through and justice for all.
I know that that stuff was great,
but uh,
I'll tell you it is slim.
Fucking pickings.
My friends,
slim pickings.
Ah,
I don't even,
I didn't know what to tell you.
Yeah.
I mean I even go back sometimes I try to listen to appetite for destruction.
I know that's this,
this watershed fucking moment in that music with some of those fucking songs
they are out to get me.
So you can stop me.
Take that one to heart.
Kill yourself.
Um,
all right.
That didn't get me a lot of fucking criticism.
Okay.
The 1980s,
they'll fuck it.
80 did I nail it though?
By the way?
Everyone had the five o one blues.
Remember that button fly dude,
I watched him three times and you're nuts.
Couldn't breathe.
You know,
and you wonder why you've got all these fucking crazy kids that need to be on
drugs now.
Hey,
what is worse hair metal or some of that fucking patriotic country music post
nine 11.
What is worse to you?
What is more cringe worthy?
You know,
um,
shout at the devil or that,
that Toby Keith,
Uncle Sam's going to put a boot in your ass.
Ugh.
Um,
oh my God.
Every dime that guy made in that song should've been thrown in his face and then
give it to the troops or something else or just,
and then the,
on the then a partial of it would be to incinerate any record that,
that,
that track was ever recorded.
The most pandering horseshit you could ever come out with,
open and Piss you guys off too much by fucking trash and all that metal shit.
You know?
I have half those t shirts and I went to go see that.
I was just embarrassed by some of that shit that I used to listen to.
Um,
okay.
Oh Jesus.
Right up until I was like 2021 fucking brutal.
What,
what,
what redeemable that I have.
Yeah.
I did listen to the Beatles,
the doors to stones,
all that white boy shit.
Stevie Ray Vaughan.
I did listen to Hendrix.
I listen to all the big band swing through my dad shift from the fifties.
Okay.
Uh,
I had such a weird musical upbringing anyways,
which was actually good because it was kind of all over the map.
MMM.
I started hanging out with Patrice back in the day.
Patrice was the one rest his soul got me the,
uh,
okay.
I still remember when he got in at that same piece of shit truck that I went to
the ACDC concert in seven fucking years later.
I'm still driving it.
Right.
Making the sacrifices.
Remember that I told you,
you don't get some fucking job and go out and buy a fucking new car.
You just change yourself to your cubicle.
I was kept Mike,
I put a new engine in the fucking truck,
had somebody slap that in there for 1200 bucks,
pay that down rather than 12 grand for a new car like it was back then.
Um,
so anyways,
I still remember
mmm.
Swinging by picking Patrice up and going into next,
and he had the cassette tape of re ready to die.
Okay.
And him putting that in.
Um,
telling me that this guy was going to be the next guy.
Okay.
And then through all of that,
like he cured me of all the rap that a white kid liked who lived in a cul de
sac.
MMM.
And he showed me all the,
all of that shit.
So I had that whole background,
all that stuff fucking held up.
But the fucking metals that I listened to,
I even watch like Lawrence Welk when I was a kid,
when the creepiest shows ever even that was fucking thrown in there.
Okay.
It's funny,
like fucking almost 40 years later I'll be walking down the street and all of a
sudden Winchester cathedral,
we'll be going through my head when Chester Cathedral Bodo Doda do yell Brang
and made down,
am I really going to sing this?
You could have done something.
Wow.
Oh my God.
Here's one for you guys.
Uh,
my boyfriend wants to have his for skin restored.
By the way,
how fresh and new are these,
uh,
these emails here,
just because it's coming from the female perspective.
I love this shit.
All right.
That's saying they don't want guys to email him,
but I,
I would like to have a nice balance here.
I already say enough shit.
Trash and women.
So it helps if women come in trash and guys,
because,
uh,
I,
you know,
it'll,
it'll be a nice balance here.
All right.
My boyfriend wants to have his for skin restored.
Dear bill,
I wanted to get your take on the situation I'm in with my current boyfriend.
Uh,
I'm a girl.
All right.
A few weeks ago,
my boyfriend of two years told me that he's become totally upset that he
circumcised and wants to restore his for skin via taping and stretching methods.
What,
and basically why he wants to do this is because everybody,
they say that,
um,
intercourse you,
you lose like,
I dunno,
some percentage of sensitivity
when you have your forced skin removed and um,
yeah,
all I can say is no guy can tell the difference whether he has a four skin or
whether he doesn't.
Because unless you got laid when you were fucking six weeks old,
you don't know what you're gaining or what you're missing.
So I don't understand why you would do this.
So t by restore has forced came via taping and stretching methods.
She goes,
I know,
I know.
It makes me want to throw up just thinking about it.
I wanted to tell him,
I think he's out of his mind.
Uh,
but I don't want to hurt his feelings.
The thing is,
I'm totally grossed out by the idea of for skin penises are gross enough
already.
There's no need to make it even grosser.
Um,
you know,
what am I the only guy that totally agrees with that?
Is there anything more fucking disgusting then I'll fucking flacid for skin
covered Dick.
I didn't know what it looks like.
Okay.
It looks like a fucking,
I don't know what it looks like.
I,
it's,
it's just fucking disgusting.
I don't even have like a reference.
Okay.
Oh,
sorry.
Going to elephant Dick.
I got,
I don't even know what to say.
It's just gross.
It's fucking disgusting.
Um,
she goes,
obviously I can't tell him how I feel.
He's clearly having a really hard time with this.
He tells me that he feels violated and disfigured.
This guy's a pussy.
This,
throw this,
throw this guy into the fucking pussy band and get on with your life.
He also claims that for skins has a lot of advantage for both partners,
but it's hard for me to totally buy that considering the fact I have slept with
a couple uncircumcised guy and I didn't notice any extra pleasure.
Although I did use a condom with both guys.
Yeah,
he's full of Shit.
He's full of Shit.
It may be more pleasure for him.
I don't know what I mean.
I think it's amazing that women will put a dick in their mouths.
You know the least she can do is try and tidy up down there.
You know?
How about happened?
Fucking empathy.
Okay.
I've asked you this discussed.
It's just fucking extra skin.
Yeah.
Nothing more sexy or then extra skin.
It's like your Dick used to be obese and then lost a ton of weight but didn't
have enough money to have that surgery.
They get rid of the extra and it's gross.
There's another two paragraphs,
people just just preparing you for another two paragraphs of having an
uncircumcised stretch tape dick in your head.
Anyway,
I think it's absolutely disgusting and totally weird that he wants to do this
and I'm starting to get really turned off by the idea of sleeping with him while
he's stretching out.
As for skin,
he told me he's going to tape it to when elastic strap,
which is going to tie around his leg.
I know what the fuck is he just coming up with this shit on his own.
Okay.
I told him that he should see a doctor before he starts to do this,
but he doesn't want,
but he doesn't think that doctors know much about this sort of thing.
Oh,
so he's just going to take it in his own hands.
Congratulations sweetheart.
You're dating a fucking moron.
Yeah,
come on.
This is the father.
You had children?
Yeah.
Coming up with,
you know,
taking an erector set to his fucking Dick.
It was he this.
Do I have to finish reading this?
I'm thinking of breaking it off with them.
Really.
Course you are.
I thought he was a normal guy,
but I had no idea he had all this freaky shit going on underneath the surface.
Anyways.
What do you think about all of this?
You got to go ll cool j
got to do what he did.
Yeah.
You stretching out your fucking Dick.
I know.
I said I'd be true.
You're stretching out your fucking Dick,
so I'm leaving you go fuck yourself.
It's over.
Yeah.
Fucking gross.
Anyway,
what do you think all this is my justify dumping him away or would that make me
an insensitive comment?
No,
it would make you a strong person.
All right?
Go with your gut on this one.
This guy is trying to,
to do the impossible,
like,
uh,
like he said,
fucking scientists and that Michael j,
Fox movie back to the future.
He's basically,
you know,
doing the Delorean bullshit with his Dick and he doesn't want to go see a
doctor.
Any doctor would tell him,
you can't do that.
Okay.
You'll be funny.
That was if you dumped this guy right,
and it actually works.
And then he starts screaming like Billy Mays on TV with his,
his Dick Stretcher.
Then he sells it for 1995.
It makes a zillion dollar.
I'm just playing devil's advocate here,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a 99% chance you're doing the right thing,
but there is a 1% chance you could be walking away from a,
a potential millionaire.
Cause I gotta be honest with you,
if,
if that guy actually pulls this off,
no pun intended,
he pulls this off,
okay.
And he's able to do it with some household material.
And then he,
you know,
Pete,
they already make millions of dollars with those,
those pills that say they're going to make your Dick Bigger,
which we all know it doesn't work because of it fucking work.
That would be an international story and um,
and then it still wouldn't work because then what would happen was everybody
would take big dick pills,
even guys with big dicks because they don't want everybody else catching up with
them.
So then having a little dick would then be like having a six inch dick as
opposed to a three inch,
four inch Dick.
Right.
It's a math workout on that or get bumped up.
You've got to six,
seven inch Dick.
He just,
he just regular,
no,
you're actually not regularly.
Yeah,
you'd have a little Dick.
So if this guy actually fucking is able to pull this,
that doesn't even make sense.
Okay.
He's going,
he,
if he thought he was disfigured now wait till he tries to fucking do this.
I mean his dick is going to look like,
you know when those people put that shit their ear Lobes,
okay?
They put those fucking,
um,
those circles,
circular things.
You could shoot a God damn fucking bow and Arrow through somebody's ear lobe and
not draw any blood.
He's going to do that to his deck,
except he's not going to have that thing in there and it's just going to be
hanging out,
right?
Bill?
We got it.
It's disgusting,
Eh?
Oh,
whoa.
Underrated.
Overrated.
Fucking voicemails leaving them as the most,
most
awkward thing.
I've always said that I'm terrible at leaving them,
but whenever I say that,
everyone else,
whenever I say that,
everyone else always says it too.
So I'm putting my foot down on the issue,
calling it right now,
leaving a message for someone on the phone sucks.
There's no way to start your message normally without sounding like a Douche.
And then five minutes later you realize you've been trailing on and on while
saying,
ah,
um,
too many times making you want to kill yourself,
ending with the inevitable.
A.
Okay,
thanks.
By reminding them that you're still a Douche.
Fucking awful dude.
This is something that's really like an epidemic in this young generation is
everybody just feeling awkward and feeling like a Douche.
I don't know what happened to you guys.
I think this last generation of fathers,
they flipped.
Like,
I'm not going to beat the shit out of my kid.
Not how them and never tell him that I,
that I,
that I love him.
Uh,
you know,
I'm going to do all of that shit and you end up with these people who can't even
fucking leave voicemails.
What is so awkward?
You know,
I,
you know what?
I have a hard time getting off the phone.
I forget.
I forget what I used to say.
Okay.
But I don't feel awkward.
Yeah.
Well,
I just feel like an idiot.
I guess.
So I guess I kind of relate.
Okay.
I just go right.
That's it.
I'm Outta here.
I will say that believe in a message.
I like leaving messages.
I sing on people's voicemails.
You know,
whenever I call up fucking Blob,
Yay.
Bobby Kelly or in fucking Joey roses.
I call him up and I,
I'll just immediately,
I'll just,
whatever comes to my mind,
I'll just start singing.
Who's the con to that?
I love the most.
Who's that fucker?
Who eats the toes?
Did Joey,
he's such a big FHEG.
Derosa what's going on?
It's bill.
Give me a call back.
You can't click.
That's it.
Why don't you try singing?
You can do it for anybody.
Hey Mom,
what's up you sweetie?
Thanks for having me.
40 years ago I sent you some flowers.
You didn't call me.
Do you like my siblings better than me?
Click right?
Why don't you do that?
Try that,
sir.
Try singing first.
Um,
all right.
Underrated.
Overrated.
Sitting Down to pee.
If you're a guy.
Uh,
yeah.
Is it that,
how old are you?
Is it that hard to stand up?
Okay.
What is wrong with this fucking generation of guys?
You Know,
Sitting Down To pee,
it's actually easier and you don't get varicose veins from all those years of
stay.
There's nothing better than just pulling out your Dick.
It just fucking pee and all over everything.
You know,
you fucking shooting the toilet paper around.
It's fucking good time.
Um,
anyways,
it says guy who drives a fucking hybrid.
Um,
anyways,
there are many benefits to being a guy in sitting down to peace,
such as not having to hear your chick complain about peeing on the seat,
even though it's on the fucking top of the bowl and it's not actually the seat.
Yup.
Here's a guy,
he's literally sitting down to pee,
so his girlfriend will stop yelling at him.
Okay.
I don't know what happened.
People a hundred years ago,
we could hit them with mop handles and I don't know what happened.
They got organized and we didn't,
and now we're sitting down to pee just so they'll stop yelling at us.
Um,
all right,
number two,
if you like me,
if you're like me and you wake up to pee at night,
you don't have to fuck with your eyes and turn on the bathroom lights to aim.
Okay?
Oh Dude.
You take it all the fun out of it.
That's how you train your ear.
All right,
that sounds like the back of the ball.
Where's the water?
That's the floor.
There it is.
One small step number three,
not bending down to lift up the seat out.
You know what,
dude?
You're a fucking pansy.
Not Bending down to clean off to see less bending in general.
Why don't you just bend over and suck your own Dick is just sit on the bowl.
You fucking Douche.
Fuck that guy peeing sitting down.
Do you know
what else,
sir?
What?
What else is overrated?
Lifting weights.
Um,
owning a gun.
Chewing tobacco.
Eating steak.
What else?
Drinking Scotch.
Smoking cigars.
Fixing your own car.
What?
What else?
Or what else is fucking overrated?
Everything that makes being a guy fucking awesome.
Losing your shit.
Because some guy you don't know Mr. Field Goal,
that really has no effect on your life.
Talking Shit.
Is that all overrated?
Lee?
Marvin's
the only thing that saved you surge.
You didn't leave your name.
So that,
that's the only thing that I can say is I can at least see that there was sort
of some,
some sort of shame in your email.
[inaudible].